we need to get back to ping pong
diplomacy with China back in the good
old days what was the 80s um with Reagan
I think it was where we had like a ping
pong team go over and they like some
friendly sport matches instead of um
blowing up each other's balloons and
spycraft the NBA is in is pretty
involved with China so I'm not I'm not
100 sure that that's working out the way
that that ping pong did
ping pong I don't I don't know if we're
in the point of diplomacy so the one
thing the one reason I thought it'd be
great to have you on as well a lot is
that you've talked before about a
unipolar versus multi-polar world for
those that aren't familiar basically
should the US be the dominant force or
should there be multiple dominant forces
like I'm kind of worried that uh yeah
you make a good point with unipolar if
the U.S falls from the top position in
terms of military power economic power
then the likelihood of conflict
increases this is through safety strap
we talk about it all the time
I don't know what the solution is though
man and and it seems like we're inching
towards a thucydides trap with China